Star Wars fans are thrilled that Jason
sindula might walk the path of the Jedi
but the latest Ahsoka episodes suggest
that things could be about to get very
dark very quickly as so katano isn't a
pickle after being thoroughly defeated
by Balin skull in the previous episode
she spends a majority of ahsoka's fifth
part trapped in the force limbo known as
the world Between Worlds her experience
there involves multiple flashbacks of
the war-torn days of her youth as well
as a ghostly vision of her old Master
Anakin Skywalker who uses some
characteristically aggressive methods to
complete his former padawan's training
back in the physical world ahsoka's
allies struggle to track her down and
once again strange Force Antics end up
saving the day Harris and duelist's Son
Jason use an impressive clearly Force
enhanced listening skill to get an idea
of ahsoka's whereabouts as he hears
Snippets of her experience in the world
Between Worlds don't you hear it
known as their enforced listening this
ability allows Force users to hear
things from great distances as power
also has other handy applications such
as allowing the user to understand the
other languages while not exactly common
in the live-action Star Wars Universe
many prominent Jedi characters have
mastered the Trek in various Legends
works the show's choice to give Jason
Thera and forced listening abilities is
particularly interesting as the skill is
closely Associates him with a similarly
named character from an extremely dead
corner of the Star Wars lore Jason solo
the son of Han Solo and Leia Organa in
many ways Jason solo is a scarier Star
Wars villain than Darth Vader a
prominent character in non-cut and Star
Wars novels he starts out as a perfectly
capable Force sensitive kid who
eventually becomes a powerful and
respected hero unfortunately the plot of
the books puts him through the kind of
ringer that would make his live-action
successor kylo Ren Run for the hills
Jason's path ultimately takes an
unfortunate turn and unlike kylo he goes
all in on the dark side as the Sith Lord
Darth kader Jason becomes something of a
tragic villain but also a true Terror
who among other things kills Luke
Skywalker's wife Mara Jade any Legends
fan will tell you that Darth kadus is
one of the most overpowered antagonists
in the entire franchise with a laundry
list of force superpowers to put him
almost on par with Luke himself he's
also notorious for picking up some of
the stranger four skills out there
including of course their enforced
listening since the live-action Star
Wars Universe has pretty much
overwritten Jason by establishing kylo
Ren as Han and Leia's only son it's
highly unlikely that he'll become Canon
anytime soon nevertheless fans would
have noticed that Ahsoka chose to give
one of his most famous forced abilities
to a kid with the same name and might
see as a red flag for sindula's future
so what could go wrong well as Kanan
jairus's son Jason has the potential to
be a truly powerful force user the fact
that he's able to use a rare and obscure
Jedi skill like pharaoh and force
listening with no training suggests a
natural Affinity with the force and the
fact that he's able to hear what's going
on in the world Between Worlds might
hint at a level of power approaching
that of Jason solo since Jason is
effectively out of the Canon picture and
the younger Jason story is largely
Unwritten look at the fact that he has
access to a similar Force ability be an
ominous hint that is destined to follow
a similar path yet sad to say for sure
but Ahsoka fans will want to keep an eye
on the young sundula as the series draws
on
foreign
[Music]